ok dann auch machtansprüche habe ich das
ficc schnitzel war fähig ist das
kriegsschiff das tier ständig da komme
ich auch zu dir sagt servus sg zh und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute wir sind im urlaub und war mit
dieser gruppe also ich hab ich nicht
gesehen wirst du noch dimitri islam erst
wieder bei mir stimmt doch gar nichts
und heutige spiel heute eine neue runde
statt dann spaßt urlaubs edition das
prinzip der ganze sache es so wir haben
durch ihre kategorien die teilweise
recht lustig denn ich sage ich wieder
und zwar natürlich in der stadt gelernt
spaß dann haben wir der
durchgestrichenen dinge die man am
strand machen kann aufmunternde sprüche
da hab ich sehr gespannt und gründer den
urlaub vorzeitig zu beenden also früher
nach hause zu veranschlagen dazu muss
man sagen wollte wir sind eine gruppe
von jungs die in urlaub fährt und dann
absolut nur sachen macht der moralischen
fortschritt dieser gesellschaft sind ja
deswegen gibt es vielleicht eher
angesagt seien verschiedene kategorien
wenn zweiten kategorie das gleiche haben
gibt es fünf punkte wenn sie
unterschiedliche sachen haben aber zwei
was haben gibt es zehn punkte und wenn
einer der einzige was hat der kategorie
u20 und übrigens leute werder die
wenigsten punkte wird bestraft der
kriegt eine runde wunsch und schnittig
sagt stoffen jetzt los aber ich sage
stopp stopp stopp wie von anderen stadt
habe ich offenbach kann das leben dann
dein land bitte hier
menschenrechte sind österreich genommen
aber wie ist das schön dass österreich
mitgenommen aus österreich ukraine so
dass dadurch ein veto einlegen
dann kommen wir zum spaß habt ihr kein
ja und ich habe ein kollege als olivier
punktebereich ich habe mir spaß onkel
der zwei dürfen und politikern wurde
besser ich habe muss ich darüber kann
genau und welchen spaß daran wenn man
sich anguckt was er früher so gemacht
aber auch ganz ohr beißen und so etwas
sind auf den 14 punkte das ist nichts
das land dinge die man am strand machen
kann
ich habe ja gar nichts aufmunterndes
sprüche morgen auch komisch
5 ich hab es sich natürlich um den
urlaub vorzeitig zu beenden wer hat da
irgendwas tolles borna ich hab's termin
ich habe das auch nicht das bietet das
rechtlich haben schwarzen zimmer
ok dann würde ich sagen zählt finden und
mozart stopp sprüche damit jetzt bleibt
stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp
stopp stopp stopp stopp fangen wir an
statt
der staat habe ich keine rede sein
hamburg oder hannah land hessen dem
motto gut weil ich finde toll an ich
habe honduras
ich habe auch immer noch und ist kommen
wir zum spaß ich habe gut ich habe zum
beispiel ist sich sicher ich habe
hansi hinterseer harald glööckler
ja ich selbst hier ist ich habe hitler
ja alles klar
dinge die man am strand machen kann wer
hat da etwas gutes morgen halten
ich habe die gute aktivität einen
hauptsatz bilden dann kommt und sprechen
hört die fresse
ich habe nichts also ich wollte damals
stand ich glaube ich und zwar ganz
gleich ob man zwar auf business blog ist
begründet in urlaub vorzeitig zu beenden
nichts muss stammt von der strecke hätte
ich mache hier nicht mit ja ich habe
geschrieben hund krank
ich habe hin zu tragen jetzt zählt nur
und sagt stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp
fangen wir an leute stadt frankfurt ich
habe auch frankfurt überhaupt kommen
wird ich habe fertig erfreuen ich bin so
ein mastermind land frankreich finnland
frankreich weil ich spaß tja was was das
motto lasst uns mal überdenken wäre der
text mit es seien könnten diese
irgendwie gut gefällt eigentlich nur
dass franken
ja ich habe filme tatsächlich das
muttersprache patrick dinge die man am
strand machen kann
die füße börse
schließlich wollte er es aber dann habe
ich früh entschieden wofür dann die
straße weiter ja genau
gerne kann aber ich habe tatsächlich
fußball
okay nicht kann man überall spielen das
klang
ok dann auch machtansprüche habe ich das
ficc schnitzel ist ja und zwar schnell
da komme ich auf studieren.de
gestresster gerade ein offenes buch
ich sag's für euch laut aber in der
kammer wichtig sind
ich würde auch immer gut von mir auch
munter mit also wenn ich das jetzt noch
mal sagen
liebst du das dann aber sei fußball oder
vorzeitig zu beenden
gut dass du auch deine erfahrung und
persönlichkeit ich habe fitnesstraining
vermisst ich habe mich tot
oder aber man kennt es dann kennt er
bitte mal punkte zusammen zählen 130 170
185 wie viel hast du dir die gegeben
170 x 95 stellen jetzt mal davon kommen
wir zur bestrafung hier sitzen noch
weiter oben dran weil ich wissen muss
den anfang wo willst du rechts oder
links mit 50 also okay das war's dann
diese leute ich hab euch jetzt mal in
folge was es geht von den täglich an ab
jetzt auch mehr material von mir wir
gehen jetzt hier anstand und